it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes what in the world is time for
movie fights what's going on everybody
we've got an exciting program of movie
questions that our fighters will debate
and a winner will emerge you know what
it's gonna be a good time trust me
let's without further ado meet our
combatants for our movie octagon first
up you know from the Schmo down and the
he is the titular character of the josh
mokuba show to be here in this half
octagon
yeah this half octagon half the gun
actually I don't even know if it's a gun
but I just like saying oh my god you
know how I come here bearing no gifts
and mostly the gift of fact that I've
never won never won a movie fight I've
never won a TV fight I'm just here to
have fun but you're entertaining all
right and I still haven't seen a wrinkle
in time yes you picked a Badou Vinay for
an answer yeah yeah last time you were
here that's like oh the bet the best
director to direct this new franchise
and then you're like oh yeah I haven't
seen any of removing I just know she's
popular okay that's my skill all right
so we're gonna thanks for being here
brother
oh um second she is from fan verse Asian
he's a good friend of the show welcome
back yell Tegel yeah thank you uh how
you feeling you ready to bring the pain
today I am ready I'm gonna I'm gonna
fight I'm gonna point out when he
doesn't know stuff good I'm excited for
that
oh that those sound like strong solid
strategy good oh good I'm glad cuz I'm
like and and I like that bling I like
that play thank you but it's it's a step
lower than me because I have my my at my
Twitter handle on my back as a [ __ ]
stamp
yell smart thank you
being on a spring break winter a lot
showing that off down in Cabo and lastly
but certainly not least Lee he is one
half of the real rejects sir welcome
Greg Alba thank you right thanks yeah
I'm happy to be here I'm nervous as hell
but I'm excited to be back after like
three years or something like that yeah
oh no worries
yeah I mean you know enter enter the the
movie octagon nervous maybe leave
victorious his hair I've seen me in the
last modown I competed and so I'm ready
to take revenge right now all right
please let's not talk about other movie
related shows you got it all right it's
a clean slate right here I'm excited for
this battle and deciding this battle
will be myself and the two gentlemen
right over there Oh Dan Murrow on the
facts hello yeah how are the facts
treating you nowadays
good I'll also be pointing out like
y'all what Josh doesn't know things I
appreciate that
partial yes you know what we should turn
that you know if you're if you're
watching at home maybe turn that into a
drinking game when Josh doesn't know
something take a shot of jäger 20
minutes in we have no audience Dan thank
you as always for holding it down over
there sir my play and that's not Daniel
Radford that is Billy Billy biz
Patterson guys I'll be checking social
you guys can vote if there's a
tiebreaker
I'm gonna spend a whole lot of time by
this point you probably get it if you
don't know how to vote all of its in the
description Ryan he made beautiful
instructions better than I could say I'm
all in the descriptions what's some fun
heck yeah thanks for holding it down
over there brother and you know if you
see any funny answers to our questions
or any bank be sure to send them
somewhere else
and just a quick reminder of how our
game works so we have three players this
is their seven total this is a
best-of-seven total game and the first
player to four points emerges victorious
we have three regular round questions
and then we shift gears two players will
go forth into the speed round and the
again the first player to pick up them
four points leaves a winner the losers
will shave Gregg elbows head will leave
in shame and well that's between you
guys any head shaving that occurs and in
the event of a tie we got tie breakers
and all that good stuff
are y'all ready yes sir okay jde is in
the booth JT drop that sick ass package
[Music]
[Applause]
jte a man with a robust package you know
III love dance
disapproving happens off-camera alright
here is question number one so uh solo
star wars story had a less than stellar
opening at the box office
whatcha Disney do with Star Wars what
should Disney do with Star Wars right
now and you guys you've got your
opinions you've got your answers you're
going to argue them now Josh we're gonna
start with you okay all right listen
Disney what solo we already knew that it
was gonna be kind of a bomb because they
had of a switch I put directors but when
we're talking about bombs they made 85
almost 85 million dollars in a weekend
okay I know that's bad for Disney but
that's pretty much like one percentile
for everybody else yeah I mean Deadpool
whatever it's gonna do whatever but for
the most part Star Wars fans aren't
there they go what to like the movie at
this point they go in there hoping that
it's terrible and that's what they were
hoping for this one they went in there
they wanted to hate it it had no word of
mouth and it is what it is but they need
to stick to the plan they have their
guns don't go all DC EU and just kind of
flip the script as soon as know what one
person doesn't like the movie
stick to the plan you have your slate
roll with it keep it there
you don't just change the game plan when
you don't get a first down on your first
play you keep on going you didn't have
this one this was wasn't yours in
comparison to the other ones just
because they didn't make a billion
dollars doesn't mean it wasn't a success
cuz it was solo a star was story was a
super fun movie I'm sorry oh you Star
Wars fans that Darth Plagueis didn't
make his way into the picture oh oh
sááá-- by ole or whatever the other
person is a nice cleaner you know what
I'm saying Dan track check that for me
that's gone
it's somebody but not so Josh says
despite a less-than-stellar opening
stick to the plan
yell what are your thoughts on what Star
Wars should do now going forward
Star Wars should hire up-and-coming
unknown there quotes on that unknown
writers and directors people are gonna
come see these movies regardless give
people a shot let's see something new
and interesting hire somebody we haven't
seen before and let them make something
creative especially if their fan they're
gonna be able to make something amazing
alright higher the unknowns higher the
unknowns
we'll hear more about that shortly Greg
your thoughts I'm liking the exact
middle spot between these two right now
I think they should maybe take a break
slow it down and spread out what they're
doing because we all know there's
several factors as to maybe why solo
underperformed really late marketing
going up against Deadpool to infinity
war but I think a big part of what makes
Star Wars exciting and special is the
anticipation factor the hype factor
behind it and solo just did not have
that Josh is right no one really cared
about it to begin win don't really
wanted to see it but with like the
marketing for the movie came out like
what two months a month and a half
before the movie actually came out so
there was no time to get excited for it
by the time it came out it just felt
like another movie and when I look back
at the first trilogy and even the
prequels there was time spread out
between those movies and now we got four
Star Wars movies in four years I don't
think they need to get an entirely new
plan but I think they should kind of do
in an MCU think that when there's a
misstep take a second to go how should
we go about executing our future
projects I could hear the shaking in my
voice but my confidence is coming right
now I'm ready to mix it up mix it up all
right so I don't think timing had
anything to do with it this is the
beginning of the summer blockbuster
season I don't think the timing affected
it at all I think what they need is
instead of continuously hiring
the same types of people they should
give other people a shot to do something
creative
how does she help you say time you had
nothing to do with it when last Jedi was
just five months ago and they didn't
even promote it at all I really feel
like these Star Wars movies would do
better if they were a once a year or
even a year and a half like keep
December in its slot if we were able to
associate December whatever you think of
December like Christmas and holidays and
if we had a movie like that if that was
Star Wars that would be special I think
timings a big part of it because there
was already so much weight and heaviness
of the last Jedi that by the time you
actually get to solo you're like I'm
already sick of talking about the last
Jedi do I really want to see another
Star Wars plan if they stick to the plan
they already know where things are gonna
be they can think inside outside the box
and how to bring in more Star Wars fans
because the die-hard Star Wars fans the
people that host shows the people that
argue at Comic Cons the people that that
they are the people they're gonna go see
it regardless they need the new
generation of Star Wars fans that people
to be like hey I think I want to see
this movie I want to see this movie they
need to think outside the box on how to
get those people in no Louie with new
writers why would you how does that ever
fix anything yes fresh set of eyes right
now it's really gonna bring it like a
director from SVU who did the one where
the guy got killed in the park I think
you're saying your writers and directors
all these films other than Lawrence past
any four give us four directors that are
new and up-and-coming that you would
like to see in it besides their name go
on they're already mixing it up with
directors oh now one person has come
back and direct like they've already had
Ryan Johnson JJ Abrams forever director
rogue one name's not coming right now
ryan johnson was but for every title i
TT for every taiko itd there are nine
other zack snyder's that just Bom Bom
Bom Bom Bom
we need directors that know what the
Star Wars world should look like and
think outside the box inside the box on
how to create these spin-offs so we
already have the saga how to create the
spin
like a Jon Favreau series keep with the
plan while you while you still have the
people that are inside of this box that
know exactly where the Star Wars
universe should go stick that plan may
be a new marketing campaign maybe the
spin-off has a new character maybe the
spin-offs creates a spin-off of a
character they have that plan in place
too close to it so you need someone
who's outside to give it fresh eyes to
look at it and go listen this is what we
could have done with so if so do you
come in and be like you know what I'm a
good heist movie director I'm gonna make
a good heist movie it would have been
great
who would you have gone with it is an
excellent question but I think they're
already working on that aren't they
they're talking about getting James
mangle for the Boba Fett movie they're
talking about getting either Game of
Thrones guys to do that new other
trilogy they already have new people in
line for this that is in place thing
about sticking to the plan though is
they're trying to build up to like a an
MCU type of situation where they're
trying they're obviously trying to build
up to gain like two to three movies a
year they got this show that Jon Favreau
is working on I think that's way too
much I'm talking about you can kind of
stick to the plan maybe cut back on some
of them spin-offs though I don't really
think we really care about above a fat
movie I don't really think care about a
Yoda movie maybe an Obi one movie but I
just think that you could kind of dial
it back slow it down spread them out so
kind of stick to the plan just really
let there be anticipation and hype
instead of just trying to throw Star
Wars in our face throughout the entire
year but you're only talked about two
movies a year MCU we can get three
enough to fame but notes are awesome and
they build up to that though and Star
Wars they we have established that there
was a trilogy than another trilogy with
years apart so by the time you actually
get to now it's like well we got four
Star Wars movies once a year that is way
too fast too much it's a lot for us to
handle at once so we want I think you
got to go back to spreading them out
because no one cared about it there was
no anticipation for this movie I've done
more Solo Cup advertising for the solo
movie everywhere you went there was a
solo cup of Millennium Falcon in your
local routes or Kroger or Wegmans where
I'm talking about reevaluating the plan
you can stick to the plan but also
reevaluate I think look let's look at
the MCU for a second what was the first
MCU movie Iron Man that was great then
what were the next two movies The
Incredible Hulk which didn't perform
well with audiences
or critics and the next one was Iron Man
2 which didn't perform well with
audiences but that doesn't mean we have
to completely wipe the whole plan out of
the equation that's why I'm saying I
don't think it's necessary to get a
whole new crew I would have rather done
in a Spider Man 4 than the Amazing
Spiderman if that makes any sense so
yeah because 2 out of the 4 movies have
been received as really good force
awakens and rogue one audiences and
critics the last Jedi was split solo and
everyone's kind of on the same page
about that being just alright or generic
but I don't think it's a course for we
got to just stop everything I just think
reevaluate and really stick to your Jon
replacing because I was excited when
Lord and Miller we're doing it because
that was the chance to get like a real
good comedy and a different kind of film
and I think if they committed to that
with their plan it would have been
better but don't you think sticking to
the plan if they were able to say this
is gonna happen this is gonna happen
this is gonna happen they're able to
give those marketing people all those
other people a way to get those people
again to get people in to see Star Wars
people like my wife who've never seen a
movie to go like she seemed like maybe
three MCU movies but you still want to
see infinity where we get her to want to
see it is if it's a different thing if
it's something new and exciting that we
haven't seen before you said that we're
gonna already get the people who are
going to Star Wars anyway so let's give
everybody else away to come in and see
it let's get Donald Glover to write the
Lando movie he's already in the
wheelhouse so stick to the plan uh yeah
can you just elaborate with some
specifics on what you mean by just like
something new and fresh and exciting I
think one of the issues for example with
so long that one of my biggest
complaints of the movie was that it's a
Star Wars movie there was a heist in it
whereas if it was a heist movie if it
was an oceans type or a bank job even
you know a group of people doing a
highest-income call thank you if you
have a good heist movie and you put it
in the Star Wars universe that's
interesting that's something we haven't
seen everything we've seen is this is
Star Wars also some things happen in it
and I think it would be really great if
we give someone who maybe is more adept
to not writing big things a chance and
let them let them work within this world
and feel it one more minute
mix it up would you guys stay with the
saga and just have pieces of the saga go
more and more or
you still have all of these spin-offs if
you were in a Korean that's why I'm
saying in the middle between you guys I
don't think you need all of these
spin-offs I don't think you need a Boba
Fett one I don't think you need a Yoda
one there they're doing that thing where
they're announcing so many Star Wars
movies and it's gonna be hard to even
keep it at one a year when that's what
will keep it being special so I think
that yeah you can kind of stick to the
plan but kind of dial it back and commit
more to your Jon replacing like you're
talking about heist movies they should
commit to that doesn't mean you have to
stop Star Wars entirely or get a
brand-new cast and crew or something
like that it's sticking to the plan a
problem like this Clint Eastwood star we
losing star wars faithful by doing all
these movies I think so
I feel sticking to the plan loses star
wars fans I think you'd be sick directly
to what they're doing now with all these
announcements in this over and
fluctuation of so many Star Wars
projects then yeah you start to lose
because it loses all sense of specialty
I think it can be done if you put
someone new in charge but why would that
really make a difference I just don't
understand why that would right now what
the plan is is the same types of people
the same old white guy who's a big Star
Wars nerd making us the movies let's put
different people with different life's
in different experiences different
backgrounds to put their views into this
time Wow all right three different plans
I'm sure Disney will not listen to any
of those Dan and how are we doing on the
facts the fact checking well I was
looking a little bit of Josh's opening
gambit about solos opening in the
context of Star Wars and other movies so
was the fourth best debut of the year if
you were gonna put it in last year would
have been the 11th best 2016 it would
have been the 10th best so that does
hold somebody for the fact that while
still his debut may not have had Star
Wars numbers it was still higher than
almost any other movie that would have
come out so I'm gonna rate that a good
fact Josh
yeah Greg brought up the marketing the
first solo chillers released on February
5th of this year that's about three and
a half months before the movie was
released force awakens and wrote one a
force awakens had a teaser over a year
before the movie's release
rogue one and last Jedi were both got
teasers eight months prior so so I had
less than half of the marketing time
that the other Star Wars guts that's
also true and just looking at the
current slate if we want to know what
the plan is right now you have episode 9
coming out next year the trilogy that
Rian Johnson is working on a series of
films unnumbered how many from DB Weiss
and David Benioff and the james mangold
book that movie that was announced to be
in the works last week this is so fun
got it oh and and we can reconfirm that
exon a Baiul is not I can confirm that
Oksana Baiul is not a canon Star Wars
thank you hello skater I look good I
look forward to seeing you guys made
some strong arguments here and yell I
thought you you know your argument
started to come together more towards
the end or and you were talking about
just the different types of stories and
making it that kind of movie just like
committing for it to be that kind of
movie I started to like see that a lot
more Josh I could have heard a little
bit more of a defense from you as far as
I mean by the other were starting to
agree with Crick I was starting to agree
with Greg as well I think he made a
great point in the fact that we were
just getting over to quote you the the
weight and the heaviness of the last
Jedi conversation before we could just
like dive into solo with this on a Bosch
Star Wars love and I feel like your
argument of dialing it back really just
resonated the most with me you know it's
not completely overhauling it but it's
like whoa we're not gonna have a mandate
to just make two movies a year so yeah I
think Greg spoke to me and I give my
point to Greg Dan
I'm similar to you how by the end I was
finding myself agreeing with Greg I
thought everyone made good arguments but
Greg for me made the most compelling
argument and well-rounded one and so I
also would go with Greg all right yeah
well by the end the Internet
overwhelmingly agreed with 72 percent
going with Greg to take a break
11 percent to hire new directors and the
writers and 15 percent just stick to the
plan Michael said and a lot of people
said this that Dave Filoni who does the
Clone Wars rebels should come into the
writing room Matthew said the main way
to fix it is to take away the
attachments from the original trilogy
and James said we're three minutes in
and I'm already on shot five of the josh
mokuba drinking game
Greg you are ahead one nothing and now
let's move to question number two Jamie
Foxx is the new spawn yes what
previously unsuccessful comic book
adaptation should get a second shot what
adaptation should get a second shot and
question number two start with player
number two yell Catwoman all right
I assume you will elaborate on that
later thank you yeah thank you yell Greg
there was a terrible 2010 film that I
think rightfully so deserves another
shot Jonah Hex Jonah Hex
yeah the Josh Brolin star oh yeah all
right now Jonah arguments in this first
we will you know what no you can't oh
yeah you can use this first opening
gambit however you like there
stay in Merle out because he sounds like
he's over there getting ready to just
type in time you start speaking dance
start searching okay there's a clear
winner in all this so funny knowing what
this is it's Billy Zane's phantom okay
it's the Phantom just listen to me
that's funny that's a very picture thank
you see reboot Billy gains finger I'm
saying
the phantom franchise is one of the
oldest comic book franchises in the
world uh-huh it is it has the greatest
name nickname for a superhero ever the
ghost who walks
that is a great great name of a
superhero yes his outfit in the original
was a little too purple you bring it
down a little bit he is a little bit of
a darker plum ain't like a harder
looking suit almost to the point of like
a Deadpool looking darker plum saying of
like the armor I'm not saying with the
knives and the [ __ ] jokes okay
what I'm saying is is that it's a darker
plum basically the Phantom is Batman
with a long lineage of people right
his dad was before him his grandfather
great-grandfather the Phantom lineage
goes back 300 years he is a human being
so he can die but everybody thinks
because of all the lineage that he is
the ghost two walks the first movie if
you watch it now
it had that 90s era almost cartoonish
you know Batman Forever kind of look
with like loud colors and big cars and
it was a period piece in the 30s this
one you bring it to the modern times I
mean he right he can ride horses he can
drive cars he this is all like Batman is
kind of stuff but it's in a different
world a separate world and he also has a
wolf as his sidekick it's a dog it's a
wolf that he's trained the Phantom the
stories in the comic book there it is an
endless supply of plot lines The Phantom
could be the next great superhero
franchise give it a chance
and also get Billy Zane a chance any
casting directors out there looking for
talent Billy Zane oh wow a plug for Zane
is cool
so are you are you positing that Zayn
should take up the role again st. is the
ageless wonder have you seen Zayn lately
my stomach okay I've not seen Zayn late
let's say he shouldn't have a fan Dan
I'm gonna make a personal request for
you to look up the picture of Billy Zane
current and and weigh in with your
personal opinion I won't whether he's
stunning or not okay fight it out
basically he's Batman we have that we've
seen that we've done it it's great no no
that basically he's bad I said he is a
Batman type human being so he's got
human he's not some superhero like
Superman who you're like well we can't
beat him we're just gonna keep doing
movies that are average the Phantom can
be beat Batman can be beat here's all of
the the franchise within Batman Michael
Keaton's too incredible the next won't
land the three Christian Bale one's
awesome Batman been back easy up and
down whatever the Phantom can create a
franchise based around his own franchise
the lineage of the Phantom it goes back
300 years not just 30 years before his
parents were killed by the Joker did you
know that the Phantom protects a
fictional area in Africa yes a fiction
so you want to see a movie about a white
man detecting a fictional country in
half you want to see Billy Zane as black
panther's we are lovers right no no to
merge the race relations it doesn't
matter if your wife let me tell you that
Catwoman okay all right we're bringing
back cat one because this is an
interesting character it's a fun
character
it's a kick-ass woman in tight leather
spandex and she is she's saved in the
city but also stealing stuff desert
naming facts about your heroes Josh no
one will give a [ __ ] about the fan so
I'm just telling you that right now
I can't my story that woman knows how to
care about it nobody would give a [ __ ]
about Iron Man and look what happened we
got the MCU you dum-dum and
we haven't done a good Catwoman that's
what's missing is we've done column and
we had Michelle white-haired 60s and
even Michelle Michelle Pfeiffer it
wasn't a Catwoman movie we're making a
Catwoman movie we're finding someone
who's right for the role we're telling
the story of Selina Kyle we are doing it
right and we're going to have it set
beautifully in the current time it's
gonna be gritty it's gonna be deciding
and all out there that like 82 percent
of people don't like cats that's no
one's gonna care about this a lot of
people there was a bunch of cats with
the Michelle Pfeiffer one so you're not
gonna have cats and Cathy let's get off
the cats for a second when okay what was
annoying when you hear about Harley
Quinn and the Joker and Killer Croc and
Suicide Squad well Batman's not in it
you hear about all these Batman villains
being announced in their own solo movies
people in the row gallery you attack you
know we'll get to that
with no Batman in it I think no I think
maybe you could do a solo Catwoman movie
way down the road after you have Batman
and Catwoman in it but no one's really
gonna care unless Batman's in the movie
grace that woman's identity goes so
hand-in-hand with who the bat is the
love interest between Bruce Wayne and
Selina defilement or the Phantom you
think people will care about a cowboy
who's two fists have you ever did after
I heard your choice I decided to humor
myself into a Google search on comic
book movies that deserve a second shot
okay Danya factor at this if he wants
okay no one lists the Phantom nobody
care about those you
not true where'd you see that the
biggest star one of the biggest stars in
Hollywood at the point okay Megan Fox
and they added it to Josh Brolin who was
killing it at the time and like 19
people see what you see yes yes he's
killing it now he was he was even that
was at the beginning of the bro Lana
song tonight when he was coming back you
had me to pitch you on some Jonah Hex
Monsieur oh yes yes Jonah you know
what's cool about the spawn reboot
they're gonna make it a heart are with
some horror elements infused in it yes
Jonah Hex the comic books is a hard are
violent gritty nasty Western thriller
with supernatural elements and horror
elements what's the end it's a DC comic
property and the thing is when Jonah Hex
first came out no one really knew who
that was like mainstream Isis it has had
a resurgence on the show DC's legends of
tomorrow Jonah Hex has been a really
popular characters are through DC wants
to stand out from something like a
Marvel property this could be their
chance to have their hard our Western
gritty thriller it's robot city called
West world
Western is something that's working
Western is a resurgence have you seen
the movie bone changes name yeah if you
got a director bone tomahawk to do this
movie DC right now they want to do films
that are separate from their shared
universe and a way to stand out and be
something unique is do something Marvel
won't do which is a hard-r movie what
was the thing we loved about Logan it's
hard it's Western vibe that it was Hugh
Jackman okay tone that I'm talking about
the Western vibe and they're trying to
even do a hard-r Joker movie I don't see
the point of that but this one would
give it a chance to be so man as a hero
or is he just he's an antihero he's a
bounty hunter we see how that Joe's he's
a vigilante he's a bounty hunter who
likes to he protects innocent people and
stuff but he's also like a gritty stuff
I would hear from each of you who would
play your who would you have play your
hero or character in the reboot grab I
would I just saw the movie upgrade with
a logan marshall green and he is a
fantastic actors and the invitation he's
great at playing characters which
traumatic past who were haunted and he
showed an upgrade that he can do
awesome awesome action scenes as well
and i think the director this could be
the director of bone tomahawk as well
okay great
Josh are you going Zane for the phantom
no I'm gonna go with the actor that
plays Robb Stark I don't know his name
but he's kind of a badass and he crosses
boundaries where they do the plays Robb
Stark he's is prime for a franchise
movie oh man I knew that name two
seasons ago okay and yell I'm gonna go
with Cameron Dov who was on ages of
shield recently playing Ruby she knows
how to descendants Cameron does
yes correct Disney descendants I haven't
yes it's a good I was going with
something we might all be aware oh that
would be incorrect now is the rest of
those already got some dumb love okay to
fight it out you guys so the problem is
taking Jonah Hex from legends tomorrow
is that that's what happened with
Suicide Squad that was introduced in
arrow they took it they made a [ __ ] a
movie and they messed it up I wasn't the
only problem
Jonah Hex in legends of tomorrow not a
series regular on there it was just that
I'm saying it's got fans got a chance to
know a different side of Jonah Hex that
would be more appealing I think so the
side isn't melted off that side I think
of what you're saying about the Phantom
2 is you're talking about Batum is
lighter you're talking about making him
darker but that never you said make him
like a darker more gritty costume when
he said he meant to make his darker and
give us a story about this young woman
who is a thief who becomes you know this
amazing fighter an antihero she's a
vigilante she's wonderful
give us Cameron Dov she wore the same
essential outfit - the mask from agents
of shield she can kick ass and give us a
story that we've seen it's a prequel
then introduce her into the DCU that way
we can see her fighting with gal gadot
so that would be amazing it would be so
awesome to introduce this as just a get
in I don't understand why we're going
with like these anti-heroes when we have
a clear hero over here your luck just
kills bad guys he she was onto something
so X is Jonah Jonah Hex is a cowboy with
a bad face in a horror film
that's just they'll have eyes and who
likes cats who has always been second
fiddle to Batman here are some ways like
Han Solo that movie didn't work either
because Simon is a hero
I sound generic no time Wow
all right before we got [ __ ] talking
over yeah three three very different
characters different movies Dan you talk
to us about facts and then please weigh
in with your opinion I have so many
facts The Phantom was launched in 1936
Batman was launched in 1939 I know there
was some stuff that was about the family
technically predates Batman the ghost
too walks other ones include guardian of
the eastern dark and the man who cannot
die which are there you go
it's Jane wolf's name is devil yep
Bangala is the fictional African country
out of which he operates the
thing I found a pole maybe the pole you
are everything probably not you're
probably just making it up a recent poll
said that only 15 percent of adults
replied that they disliked cats strongly
like cats they disliked cats so so 15
percent dislike just like them strongly
yes so not quite Richard Madden is yes
and I found some pictures of Billy Zane
on the beaches of Greece that were taken
last week as a matter of fact and he's
keeping it together
but you won Richard Madden over saying
no but zing can play the father all
right Dan oh do me a favor send me a
couple of those Zane picks all right
yeah after the show huh thanks I think
that strangely I I'm going with Josh
here I think that he batted away the
counter-arguments that were sent his way
I think he gave a great pitch for what
the hero could be I think a lot of I
think people thought it was gonna be a
joke and just surprised I think caught
everybody off guard was how much he was
ready to show around about the Phantom
so I'm going with Josh certainly had a
great deal of passion but I felt like I
got the clearest picture of what the
movie would be in the the vision for the
reboot from Greg so I got to go Greg
with Jonah Hex even though there was
some good information regarding your
characters and your movies from
everybody I felt like just that painting
that hard our Western gritty thriller
and the tonally I got more of an idea of
it so they get my point we're tied up at
1-1 this is a great moment in sports
let's go to Billy not Billy Zane Billy
biz to decide this was audio
I could be well there were a surprising
amount of zany acts in the chat we're
not able to to get you over the hump
there Josh at 32% the Phantom 21%
Catwoman 46% Jonah has and that puts
Greg over the top for that one it is 200
Greg but don't forget this is anybody's
ball game always all right black shirts
Josh yeah you're still in this by the
way were there any other fund
suggestions yeah a lot of cool
suggestions a lot of people saying the
shadow knows what evil lurks in the
hearts of man and just a lot of people
wondering exactly where we are right now
in the bro Renaissance everything's
coming up rollin my vote would be for a
steal and get Shaq to do it again that
was all right question number three it's
- oh great
- oh great but it's anybody's game all
right 2001 a Space Odyssey is enjoying a
limited rerelease in theaters go see it
if you haven't uh what movie must be
seen on the big screen to be fully
appreciated what movie has to be seen on
the big screen to be appreciated and we
are going to start with Greg okay when I
was thinking about this question I was
trying to think of something sounds like
such a movie fights opening line well
done yeah when I was thinking of this
question I was thinking about what's a
movie that you can like but when you see
it on the big screen that's something
where you go now I get it now I love it
I feel like you could take any iconic
movie and put it on the big screen to
probably bet or whatever any movie most
likely but the movie that is the best on
the biggest screen I'm talking
the IMAX not AMC Burbank 16 a universal
Dunkirk what are you throwing them out
for it held a nice crowd that works
there yeah that's amazing yeah thanks
but I'm saying universe like the
Universal IMAX is a real IMAX and
Dunkirk was a film when when Christopher
Nolan was testing the sound in the
picture quality he would always go there
because Dunkirk was specifically about
the movie theater experience that's a
film you could watch at home like it'd
be like I don't go the hype is about
when you watching an IMAX tur like now I
get it the sound the picture its
immersive it is a film that you will
fully appreciate when you watch an IMAX
all right Greg praising Dunkirk and
firing shots at Burbank and remember
when they do have their Star Wars
showing let's come around to Josh I'm
going with the classic the one that
started at all Raiders of the Lost Ark I
think that movie is I've seen it in rear
elisa's I've seen in IMAX if it is
showing somewhere in a movie theater it
is the movie the quintessential movie to
see on the on the big screen if I ever
have kids that it will be the first
movie I take them to is that
irresponsible absolutely but they need
to know what good movies were what good
action movies were from the sounds of
the punches to the giant ball rolling at
you to even the spiders on the back of
his friend at the beginning when they're
walking through to him running over the
hill to catch the plane as them chasing
him there is nothing like being fully
immersed as one man chases the Ark of
the Covenant like Raiders of the Lost
Ark in the big screen all right thank
you sir yell Tegel I chose a movie that
you may think is not a great movie but
in a big-screen experience it is
beautiful to watch
the colors are glowing from the screen
the the costuming can be fully
appreciated and the explosions the
gunfire the dance routine that's right
I'm talking about sucker punch good god
cool all right
Sucker Punch not a lot of sucker punch
references on movie fights you know
thank you for broadening our horizons
here fight it out y'all so I feel
sucker-punched just by your choice thank
you
the question is a movie to be fully
appreciate these are both movies that
people appreciate already to appreciate
sucker-punch you have to see it on the
big screen like the quintessential Zack
Snyder movie so I saw sucker punch one
time yes and I still don't know what the
plot talked about to appreciate the
beauty of the usual effects
that's like saying transformers is
better on the big screen that's the and
that's how you'll appreciate just
because it's better doesn't mean you'll
fully appreciate it I watch every
Transformers movie and it's better on
the picture but I still hate those much
is the same Sucker Punch does have flaws
but it is beautiful the effects are
gorgeous the costuming while getting
paid for this bundle
I like the Zack Snyder trust me I'm not
a big fan of Zack Snyder films I did
appreciate the way that he put this
movie together it's it's you how did he
do that cuz he's died in my mind the
movie was never put together as a
green-screen and computers listen to the
beautiful visual effects that that team
put together and made you're arguing of
colors you're not arguing movie you're
arguing colors I'm arguing [ __ ] you
scream yeah used to that that when your
watch it's like every Zack Snyder movie
Watchmen you're like that's beautiful
then after 20 minutes from like mattes
is kind of dull and that's the same
thing with sucker punch it's the same
thing with Dunkirk that's not true at
all Dunkirk is a movie that when you go
on IMAX when you go to the biggest
screen that's the movie about putting
you in the immediate what about that's a
movie about putting like in their shoes
big screen but it's like you know like a
regular movie theater is does Dunkirk
still hold up as like you have to see I
think it just matters and I think IMAX
is the best but I think it still holds
up in a big screen Dunkirk what is that
it's sand and water and explosions oh
it's so much more than that it's
practical effects it's real stunt work
it's real landscapes it's actual that's
the movie that puts you in their shoes
the whole point of Dunkirk is not only
wants you to feel like you're in their
fear you're in their position and the
only way to feel that is being immersed
in a big movie screen Raiders of the
Lost Ark Josh
so people already love them
movie whether or not you watching the
theaters are at home it's an iconic
movie yeah we're not but think of one of
the movie come out 81 or something so it
came out at 81 after 81 it's garnered so
many fans I saw I've never seen that in
the theaters and I love the hell out of
it now but I don't you ever experience
it in the big screen Terminator 2 or the
matrix but at home you sure you could
but it will change it'll blow your mind
how much different that movie is in the
big screen versus your 40 inch screen
though this is not good but you watch it
on a big screen it's worse and get
sucker-punched beautiful women are
beautiful the the dancing is beautiful
again the the visual effect of them
going into aliens and the war punch has
like a 20 something percent on Rotten
Tomatoes that is from people who saw it
in the theaters they clearly did not
appreciate the movie even though they
saw it on the big screen for 48 Rotten
Tomatoes fake accounts that he is
freshening for Sucker Punch Egypt Craig
C Francis Bryan Colangelo yes correct
good cause 76ers okay Greg yes sir you
summon it four times real quick yeah
Dunkirk in the theater versus Dunkirk on
TV does the plot of the movie change or
is it just louder no it's about
immersive that's the keyword I'm using
right here you want to be immersed in it
in an average war film that really has
not an average next time you see me you
can sucker punch me but right now it's
not working
I brought Romero tune the matrix because
those are my two favorite films I didn't
see any of those in the theaters until
two years ago in an arc light screening
but I already loved those movies when
you came out was it was your day not
made
readers of the law story what is it
about Raiders that's so much better in
the big screen cuz we've explained
what's better in the big screen what's
better is you are actually in the cave
you are actually with though you Nazis
melting you are surrounded by that sound
when they when they release that movie
that movie but was meant to be seen in
the big screen
punch there's no way you should watch
this on your laptop when people watch
Raiders of the Lost Ark they'll say I
love it even at home so if you go to the
theaters you're not gonna go you know I
like where's a lost art now that's on
the theaters now I love it
Dunkirk is that movies oh I like it but
you watch the theatres now you love it
let me go see Dunkirk okay let me come
to go and see Dunkirk in the theater
they want guys like nah still pretty
boring yeah I want to hear a little bit
more of your Sucker Punch interesting
Sucker Punch it's about these women that
have been taken they're put into this
into this asylum and they're trying to
find a way out and escape through their
minds and they escape to these beautiful
scenes and these beautiful action
alright British River whoa Dan give us
some facts the fact is I just saw
Lawrence of Arabia on the big screen
that's the answer but beyond that stars
eyes are they from blue or O'Toole's
eyes or the ocean and glory if I feet
tall yeah sorry I got lost thing about
Lawrence of Arabia ah yeah straight as
the Lost Ark was released in 1981 my
stomach does have a 23% current rating
on Rotten Tomatoes with an average
rating of 4.0 and 47% audience rating so
what was what's the Rotten Tomatoes
score on Dunkirk on Dunkirk very high
it's very high it was low 80s high 90s I
believe 92% Wow all right so people
thought it was boom you know i yeah i'm
i was i was pleasantly surprised how
excited you got me
I to watch sucker punch like just you
really just kind of put forth the visual
pastiche that is that film and I think
there are some elements that can be
appreciated rather than just like
calling it a mess and forgetting you so
it's my goal
yeah and that being said I cannot give
you the yeah but that was I mean yeah I
think you deserve props cannot point
seek to challenge myself
yeah for sure I was amazing and you you
stepped up to that challenge I think any
other person could not have made us good
an argument as you doesn't yes that was
that was impressive yeah so I came down
to Greg and Josh for me and there was a
moment Greg where Josh called you out on
like does it it works in the IMAX would
work in a regular I mean is it is that
necessary to see in a regular-sized
movie theater and you're like I think it
does if you didn't like the wrong word
you pulled up a little bit where Josh
was listing scene after scene that could
come to life and just be that much more
exciting and malicious and as a whole
experience of watching the movie on the
big screen
Josh soul mate Josh gets my point let's
go over to Dan for me it was a sucker
punch no unfortunately listen I am one
of the people that Josh described among
Kirk I saw it on the big screen it was I
had some issues with the movie while I
thought it was technically a brilliant
film and so like I'm kind of the person
that Josh was talking about having said
that the arguments made
I thought Gregg's were stronger as to
why it needed to be seen on the big
screen just certainly sold me my Raiders
the Lost Ark is a great movie mm-hmm but
Greg sold me bet on white Dunkirk would
have to be seen on the big screen and
I've got to take myself out of it and do
it based on the arguments so I'm going
with Greg dingy all right we are at 1:1
between Josh and Greg
Billy yes please decide this for ya
look once again the Internet is in favor
of Gregg 60% for done Wow
31% for Raiders of the Lost Ark heroes
7% more bind sucker punch oh I'm
impressed all right probably Zak and all
his friends so ok you get the point so
you are up 3 you're up 3 zip but this it
was a whitewash in the regular three
rounds so we are going to the tiebreaker
between Yale and Josh to decide who goes
this is gonna lose this to the speed
right great all right so this is going
to work much like the speed round except
there won't be a rebuttal each player
gets 20 seconds to argue their answer
okay 20 seconds to argue their answer
and whoever speaks first will get to go
first here is the question what actor
who doesn't have one should get their
own taken style action franchise Brad
Pitt Jamie Dornan Jamie Dornan Josh 20
seconds begin when you speak Brad Pitt
is an American treasure Liam Neeson is
not an American treasure he is a
treasure worldwide and those taken
movies did that for him what Brad Pitt
needs to do in one of these movies is
save the day movie after movie after
movie usually eating in movies we need
him fighting in movies
we need that old Fight Club style Brad
Pitt slow them down
watch him knock people out just a time
Jamie Dornan as you may know is very
well known for some crappy movies but
he's very well known also for the fall
the fall is this amazing series where he
plays a serial killer on the run that
performance in it
self shows you that he could easily take
a very cool take in series where he is a
good guy where he is saving people he
knows how to be mysterious he knows how
to be dark time Wow
all right yes somehow out soul Jamie
Jordan to Brad Pitt yeah are you
conceding did you want to alright let's
see if we get some rebuttal South could
I could I get a judging request it just
have some brief rebuttals okay sure
let's let's see okay we're shifting
on-the-fly we're Dan wants rebuttals
he's gonna get him so ten-second
rebuttals ten-second rebuttals Cougs you
didn't think you could see Brad kick-ass
more but he's back and he's doing it
those rippling muscles from Troy are
back in action Ben yell unfortunately
Brad Pitt is a little bit on the older
side and doesn't have those rippling
muscles from Troy Jamie Dornan is up and
coming he is still fit and he can do it
we've seen him tie knots we've seen this
Bank all right there you have it
alright so Billy if we're tied we're
will go to you with your opinion to the
side here yeah as as much as I hate to
vote for anyone who has anything to do
with the Fifty Shades franchise I know I
know
yell I feel like you absolutely gave us
the more compelling argument and yeah I
mean I would have asked that you just
embraced the older pit because like Liam
Neeson is running around with a shirt
off trying to stop Albanians you're
right alright um so I got I got yell
damn yeah second time's the charm for
the ridiculous answer but a great
argument because I was yeah it was an
uphill climb for the convinced we
thought Jamie Dornan and yell did that
handily for me so I agree
yo yeah Billy any thoughts otherwise
yeah I think though that 10-second
rebuttal was not a friend do you
you're correct I went into this it's
like every day and I came out of it
being like in the history of movie fight
says anybody bombed harder and it's
speed round that night with that kind of
lead on the answer no yeah that thank
you
alright so the speed round is set Greg
is rough blue you know but it's
anybody's ballgame there's going into
the speed round yellow might want to
write stuff down when it how many there
you go alright so before but when any
one of them then you take the game right
here alright so again there's no point
because she beat me not oh no no not
that was just a timer in Iceland if you
beat me four times
alright reestablished for everybody how
this little part of the dog-and-pony
show works so the speed round I'm gonna
ask a question the first person to
answer gets to go first and then you get
20 seconds 20 seconds and then 10 second
rebuttal ten second rebuttal
kind of like I just saw and Dan put his
finger right on it when he said that
Greg you are at game point all day long
here you're at three oh so one more and
you win
so yell basically you gots to sweep the
speed round if I can I've seen her fight
she can do it you can do it
yeah did that not that I could do it
again oh he grabbed a you've been there
alright Greg are you ready I'm ready
seconds than ten seconds right yeah so
Greg is up three Oh first person to four
wins here is a question Oh from one of
our fine fans who donated for our women
in film event this is from Spencer hunt
what is the best cliffhanger ending to a
movie
infinity war it was definitely what I
was gonna say I hate to do this the
first 50 shades and no fifty fifty
shades of gray that one got the rare jte
what okay the first fifty shades movie
versus infinity war Greg you spoke first
20 seconds begin when you speak it's
been a long time since we've had a
cliffhanger that has led everyone to be
wondering what is the next one going to
be there are theories there are
speculations people were shocked I saw
three times in the theaters and every
time people watch it there's gas in the
air that's the movie that it's like oh
maybe they might come back but you're
still really impacted by it Fifty Shades
great it's like when that movie edge
like well there's gonna be two more slit
at the end of infinity or I don't think
anyone went what's gonna happen next
everyone went well a lot of these people
signed a lot of contracts I'm pretty
sure they're all coming back I don't
think these are gonna stick but at the
end of 50 shades were you watching the
entire movie of two people meeting and
then they break up at the end you're
like why did I sit through all of this
what is happening right now
that's a cliffhanger what is going on
that's a clipping or not oh this isn't
gonna stick Fifty Shades of Grey is
based on a book so everyone knew what
the next one would actually be so the
cliffhanger thought that exciting
infinity war no one was expecting Thanos
to win so when he wins you're like
that's very different than a Marvel film
and everyone's when who will come back
yeah but nobody expected him to win but
they know that again people are coming
back because they have contracts whereas
Fifty Shades you went wait so they're
broken up what does that mean for this
because people didn't read past the
first book cuz it was terrible oh
alright yeah making an argument
yeah that people didn't rape at the
first one alright let's let's go to
Billy biz with his thoughts on this well
I thought this was over before it
started but I've never seen someone take
a pile of [ __ ] and make legible art out
of it I mean just for for just sheer
quality of argument I'm gonna go with
yell nice one nice seriously thank you
damn this is was not as I did not expect
this to be closed which is why I wrote
with town would you towel towel would
you throw a tie yeah III I honestly
don't know I honestly don't know yeah I
all right I'll take it and yeah I would
throw it to a tie I would give it to to
Greg just for listing the the the
reactions in the theater and the
everything surrounding our expectations
going in
I think yell made more of a game out of
the out of the point then I expected but
it was a little bit was like what what
did I just watch where as infinity war
you were along for the ride and the [ __ ]
that stuff happened and should happen
and yeah but but and then Greg I think
it imparted to us how the theater felt
and yeah that experience connected with
me more so I'd give it to Greg I've been
replays the time for I replayed the
arguments in my head and I think because
Greg did bring up a good point about the
fact that it was in a book and you know
going forward that like it's not a
cliffhanger because you could read ahead
and I think if yell had brought up that
infinity war is also based on material
that I would have given it to her
however she didn't so I think I have to
give it to Greg Greg takes it whoa
nicely done
great yeah yeah yeah you came in with
with a crackling boys winter but you you
cracked the whip during the game and you
won the whole damn thing um please go
ahead and not plug some stuff tell us
where we can find you I'm on YouTube I'm
now a little more nervous for some
YouTube the real rechecks channel that i
have twitter greg alpha Instagram the
Greg Alva yeah we do like reaction
reviews sketches every other month it's
a fun time compete on the Schmo down and
lose a lot so yeah it's finally nice to
win something for taking that's a good
buddy of mine actually Greg nicely done
well you came in and you crushed it you
crushed and brother and Joshua Kouga you
got a lot of people drunk at home I did
as per usual I didn't win but I don't
come here to win hell
I come here to entertain and to make Dan
do Google searches searches nothing but
I succeeded in doing that once again and
thought it was a great fight all the
guys around there was a lot of fun at
Josh McKoon good Twitter and Instagram
and Josh Lucas show on YouTube oh hell
yeah
thank you sir yo you had some great
arguments right answers
well well fought throughout please go
ahead and bug some stuff and whatnot
yeah I'm everywhere at yell to go that's
why a ELT yg il and you can see
interviews with the cast of
cloak-and-dagger Marvel's new freeform
show on fan ver station calm and I'm
also on afterbuzz after this I'm going
to talk about line orders Special
Victims Unit
well the greatest show of all time well
right on yellow thanks so much thank you
uh Dan Morelle thank you for holding it
down on the fact-check thoughts anything
you want anything upcoming excited about
I'm being told by our movie fight
statisticians that this is the first
clean sweep in movie fights history whoa
I don't know that's true I don't know
the show is certainly in the modern era
yes so that's a you know something for
the record books
like to point out that somehow the
internet was rigged and those poles are
rigged cuz they gonna say that all the
time on huh
so there won't be the first to point
that out every week doesn't matter yeah
but exactly yeah no mmm be nice be nice
to each other yeah and there's a there's
some some actually good movies out that
you go see a theaters do some research
find some good ones you know I mean the
big ones are nice but there's some
little ones that are spreading out
around there to go see so you know you
like yeah nobody that you dig always
good to remind people to see stuff
besides the tentpole blockbusters thank
you sir find something like Billy biz
thank you so much for holding it down
yeah and yeah any any anything else you
want to anything you want plug um just
just watch sju everyday on screen
jockeys news at 11 it's terrific
and also I'd be remiss if I didn't say
it because everyone in the chat had a
fit it's a dove Cameron not Cameron dove
that's a fail on my part I did not get
so yeah it's two first names yeah I say
thank you to my girlfriend Olivia and my
partner on the real rejects best friend
John for helping me practice my
arguments thank you you know everyone
thanks to Billy Zane I thought you were
gonna send out an obvious thanks to
absolute voice I want to thank everybody
for watching um I'm Hal Rudnick hit me
up on Twitter and Instagram at Hal
Rudnick and please join us again next
week thanks to all the fighters thanks
to a jte in the booth and yeah thanks
again for you to watching ah